in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
doctor I wished thanks for inviting me
into your clinic pleasure many of my
patients are concerned when it comes to
radiation exposure when you take x-rays
and what do you think of radiation
exposures in CT scans well CT is a
relatively radiation intensive imaging
modality so it has more exposure than
conventional x-rays on the other hand in
the recent maybe decade or so industry
has provides us with tools for
significantly lowering the radiation
exposure of CT so we are now talking
about a reduction by two-thirds or maybe
even three quarters of what it was like
about ten years ago and what about MRI
scans I mean there are no radiation
exposures whatsoever in the MRI scan but
people are always afraid of the noise
the machine makes they're scared some
noise reduction techniques are coming on
the market so it's getting a little bit
silent but it will never be at entirely
quiet examination this is got to do with
the new physics of the of the whole
process but the machine is very tight
and narrow and so so the patient afraid
that they got stuck inside the machine
it is narrow it is true although the
boers of the of the of these holes have
become somewhat bigger recently so it's
not quite as narrow and also the tunnels
are not quite as long as there used to
be a little bit less crossed
claustrophobic there are open machines
which are which have more of a gap for
the patient however they do not produce
the same image quality so therefore
we're not so happy about these open
machines on the whole the development of
radiology is closely linked to the
development of computers why is that
some of the middle modalities like CT
for example produce really vast amounts
of data of three-dimensional data at
very very high precision and processing
this data to the detail that we that
we're now used to and also with an
acceptable speed something that's only
become possible with the rapid
development of computers but if all the
data is in form of computer and storage
available we can send the data of the
picture
by the Internet worldwide without any
borders so does it mean that our views
for instance can send you and their
x-ray pictures and you take a look at it
and make a diagnosis yeah well
theoretically yes of course it is very
easy to send these images around the
world provided they're not too large and
this is very useful for a second opinion
for example however it's very important
that not only we take the pictures but
we interpret them with the patient with
knowledge about the patient so we need
to know what computer patients
complaints are we need to know what may
be other examination results are and
then we put this all together into a
report which hopefully eventually gives
the correct diagnosis of this patient
sorry still doctors and you do the
examination as well absolutely radiology
is not all about x-rays and making
diagnosis you can even treat patients
with something called interventional
radiology what is that well
interventional radiology really started
off as part of angiography and geography
is a technique where we insert tiny
little catheters in two patients
arteries via the groin and then we
inject contrast and make x-rays of the
arteries and this is something we've
done for decades and some smart
radiologists started thinking about the
option of not just using this for
diagnosis but for actually using the
catheters in the arteries for treatment
and those monitors you can see a patient
very actually closed up an artery so
what happened there this is a patient
and who had bowel cancer in the past and
has recently developed metastases to the
liver he was operated on those
metastases once but then one of the
metastases came back which we can see
here on the image so what we did was we
interrupted the blood supply to the
liver as you can see here with a
catheter in the liver vessels supplying
the tumor and we blocked those arteries
with little particles and in addition we
inserted a number of different into the
tumor under image control these probes
are used to heat the tumor and then with
the combination of interruption of blood
supply and heating we destroy the tumor
and then the patient came back recently
810 months later for follow-up imaging
which very nicely shows that the tumor
is that this area has now shrunken is
transformed into a scar the tumor
remains to be controlled and there's no
new tumor so the patient is at the
moment tumor-free so it's like you
remove parts of the liver without
actually removing it out of the body so
it's not like scar tissue so to say very
fascinating it what waits in the future
in the field of railroad radiology well
radiology is a very very rapidly
developing field with the very fast
computers we have nowadays we can handle
amounts volumes of data that we thought
was that was unthinkable until quite
recently and I think this will continue
and computers will not only show us even
nicer images but I think they will they
will help us making diagnoses so they
will propose which areas on the skin
might might be abnormal and what they
might represent so this will change the
role of the radiologist and will further
improve our quality and ultimately help
our patients thanks so much for inviting
me today into your clinical trials
exactly it's very pleasure
you